[Music]
one of the trainers who works that body
by Simone will be whipping people into
shape on khloe kardashian's new show
revenge body
Cameron Mathison sat down with Chloe
today to talk about how she totally
transformed her own figure so I asked
it's Chloe out for revenge did you get
your revenge body to get back
I was always chubby and I always just
you kind of just owned it like no I'm
just big-boned and this is just who I am
but I used to be told by stylist
I don't style people your size so my
revenge is not towards one person it's
more for everyone who was so cruel to me
and really shunned me call this the
before-and-after payback for years of
being called the fat Kardashian sister
Chloe lost 40 pounds thanks to a year of
5 a.m. workouts let's not just pull some
secrets of rapid-fire but some workout
things you tell me if you tried it if it
worked
if not I'll start with a waist trainer
tried it and I think it works skinny to
cleanse yes tried it I think it works go
to the bathroom detox body wraps no
freeze the fat yeah you tried that is it
work I don't know but I think I've tried
it it's like it like suctions you and
it's cold right I love that you're not
exactly how 2% sure he's just like I'm
like okay sure like I like trying things
or girls it's fun how about this one
but enhancement cream no no I don't
think I don't think I need it
top 5 things that you did to get your
revenge body I drink um 3 to 4 liters of
water a day when I cut out dairy I lost
11 pounds in less than two weeks it was
the hardest thing I've ever done I
really do believe jump roping is one of
the best cardio things ever if you could
do 20 minutes I think it's over a
thousand calories it's crazy
white starches is good to cut out but
and I cut out all sodas and juices
either buckle down and take it seriously
or I'm just gonna have to drop you and
get somebody
Chloe fronts eight episodes of the
kick-butt lose weight transformation
show but is it sending the wrong message
do you need to be thin and beautiful to
be happy no not at all
I don't believe that a weight defines
you I don't weigh myself because I don't
care at all what number I am I think to
be happy that comes from within I think
there's so many miserable people that
are thin and they are hungry
[Music]
you